[Musique]
très prometteur et l'imaginaire
commencer la soirée s'annonce t a pas de
gagnant au sine qua n'y avait tout dit
lancôme ternissent alyssa
milano
[Musique]
imaginer le futur pour tenter d'oublier
un passé douloureux
dylan et sa soeur graciela ont perdu
leur père des suites du coc vide
aujourd'hui sans revenus leur mère doit
prendre la famille en charge
pour cela elle est aidée par l'ina beef
le programme national pour le bien être
familial qui dépend du ministère de la
femme tous les deux mois elle reçoit
environ 100 euros par enfant
mon mari est décédé il ya deux ans et ça
fait encore mal
excusez moi mais l'aide financière que
je reçois me permet de m'occuper de mes
enfants en tout cas pour le moment ça me
permet de ne pas avoir à m'inquiéter
pour les frais scolaires et les dépenses
alimentaires parce que nous n'avons
absolument rien donc c'est d'une grande
aide pour nous en tant que veuve bien
sûr ça m'aide beaucoup
mais au delà de l'aide financière c'est
aussi un soutien psychologique que lina
beef apporte aux enfants et au conjoint
survivant
l'aspect émotionnel est encore plus
important parce qu'on aide les familles
à mettre en place des stratégies et des
outils pour pouvoir faire face à ces
épreuves
au pérou environ cent mille enfants ont
perdu au moins l'un de leurs deux
parents pendant la pandémie
c'est le nombre le plus élevé enregistré
au monde
[Musique]
aujourd'hui près de 18000 famille dans
cette situation bénéficient de l'aide de
l'ina beef
[Musique]
dans cet autre famille du district de
san juan del hooligans chaud le père
décédé du coc vide a là aussi laissé une
famille dans le désespoir le plus total
j'ai perdu ma maison mais bon les choses
matérielles ça se récupère par contre
j'ai perdu mon mari j'ai fait tout mon
possible pour le sauver je me suis
endetté me nous a quittés il ya eu des
moments où je sentais que je ne vais pas
pouvoir continuer mais grâce à dieu mes
enfants sont là et ce sont eux qui me
donne la force d'avancer et maintenant
cette aide que je reçois est très
importante pour moi est très précieuse
c'est lequel tomber sa montre nous
tout ce qu'elle rapporte de l'école elle
n'accroche sur la photo de son père
[Musique]
le pérou a été frappé de plein fouet par
la pandémie de covile 19 durant de longs
mois les services de réanimation étaient
saturés avec 212 mille décès pour 33
millions d'habitants le pays affiche le
taux de mortalité le plus élevé au monde
alors que les contaminations marque le
pas les effets se font toujours sentir
elina beef prévoit de soutenir davantage
d'orphelins à travers le pays
nous visons d'abord 25 mille
bénéficiaires avant d'atteindre 85 mille
ou 90 milles dans les prochaines années
nous sommes en train d'établir un
registre des orphelins ce qui n'a jamais
été fait au pérou et c'est probable que
les chiffres soient plus haut que ce que
l'on avait calculé
dans les quartiers pauvres de lima la
pandémie a laissé des traces les soupes
populaires permettent encore à de
nombreuses familles dans le besoin de se
nourrir quotidiennement parmi elles des
veuves et les orphelins
où
plus de 3 millions de péruviens sont
tombés dans la pauvreté depuis le début
de la pandémie en mars 2020
malgré les aides de l'état aux plus
démunis l'avenir des orphelins du coc
vide reste sombre
[Musique]